as the Sun set the Wester dam at last
arrived in welcoming waters after
receiving permission from the Cambodian
government it docked in Sein Oakville
but no one is allowed off yet medical
tests had to be conducted to confirm
they were free of the corona virus al
Jazeera spoke to one of the passengers
on board about the conditions inside
it's very disappointing to be told time
after time that were that we're going to
dock and that you know then to find out
that you know you're not going to be
allowed into that country so that's
worrisome but I should say that you know
life on board the ship is is just fine
and normal there are no restrictions
there are 20 people on board who are
unwell so blood tests were flown by
military helicopter to the capital /
Phnom Penh
for further analysis based on
information kept on the ship so we had
to test the 20 that they feel that they
might hit something but some again I
talked to out dr. Vargas and some money
Hague and okay this guy might might be
saying okay always concerned from
governments about the Wester dam stemmed
from an outbreak of the virus on board
another cruise ship more than three and
a half thousand people have been
quarantined on board since it arrived in
the Japanese city of Yokohama on
February the 3rd while it was at sea for
nearly two weeks
the Wester dam had no confirmed cases
but was turned away by Guam Japan the
Philippines Taiwan and Thailand the
arrival of this ship may also be viewed
as a public-relations win for the
cambodian government led by Prime
Minister Hun Sen who sought to downplay
the threat of the virus and emphasize
his country's strong relationship with
China where the outbreak began last week
he traveled to Beijing to meet Xi
Jinping China's president praised
Cambodia's decision to maintain flights
between the two countries and allow
Chinese nationals to continue entering
Cambodia those moves were also welcomed
by the World Health Organization the
bridge who does not recommend Java and
the cheetah restriction
in that context w really appreciate the
decision and the highest level
government leadership to receive this
shape Cambodia will also be praised by
those on board the Western M when they
eventually disembark and return home
Wayne hey al Jazeera sir not ville
Cambodia